kovat 19 has silenced entire cities this
is the tourist metropolis of Venice now
look at it a hundred million Europeans
are on lockdown in Italy the number of
dead and infected is rising steadily in
its latest crisis briefing the World
Health Organisation urged countries to
strengthen efforts to control the
outbreak you cannot fight a fire
blindfolded and we cannot stop this
pandemic if we don't know who is
infected we have a simple message for
all countries test test test
in the Spanish capital Madrid military
were on the streets telling people to go
home
Spain's followed Italy's lead confining
citizens to their houses unless they
have to buy food medicine or seek
medical help Germany the economic
powerhouse of Europe responded to the
crisis on Monday by restricting public
gatherings and tightening its borders
with Austria France Switzerland
Luxembourg and Denmark several of
Germany's neighbors including Denmark
Poland and the Czech Republic already
closed their own frontiers as the virus
advances the global race to produce a
vaccines gathering pace in Germany this
firm hopes to have an experimental low
dose coronavirus of vaccine ready by
June or July available for human testing
the company moved to deny reports that
the US President Donald Trump offered
large sums of money for exclusive access
to it elsewhere in Europe Paris woke to
its first business day of sweeping
restrictions in the UK where things have
been more relaxed the Prime Minister
announced a new raft of emergency
measures without drastic action now
Boris Johnson said cases of the virus
could double now is the time for
everyone to stop non-essential contact
with others and to stop all unnecessary
travel we need people to start working
from home where they possibly can and
you should avoid
pubs clubs theaters and other such
social venues as the number of virus
cases increases in Romania a network of
volunteers is growing in Bucharest to
help elderly people forced into self
isolation for the vulnerable these are
anxious times country after country the
situation's been deteriorating rapidly
Europe's leaders are calling on their
citizens to remain united by being
further apart